depuis plusieurs mois à ce dîner
originaire de lui en cours est à la
recherche d'un emploi après plusieurs
expériences dans la vente il est
néanmoins ouvert à toute proposition que
pourrait lui présenter cette agence
d'intérim cv elle a pris un peu les
informations qu'elle avait besoin de
savoir sur moi énormément voilà j'espère
être au contact et à la fin de la
semaine pour moi comme quand même là
j'ai six agences d'intérim étaient
présentes
c'est la première fois que la ville de
guyancourt organise ce type de
manifestation objectif permettre aux
demandeurs d'emploi d'avoir un premier
contact et d'échanger avec les
recruteurs les agences d'intérim nous
ont fait part effectivement de de ce
souci de pouvoir recruter quelquefois
sur des postes soit pas hautement
qualifiés ou mais des postes
effectivement de maintenance et donc
mais y'a tout il ya dans la restauration
il ya énormément de profil qui sont
proposées aujourd'hui les candidats
étaient invités à laisser leur cv auprès
des agences une démarche déjà bénéfique
pour certains j'ai une bonne surprise je
me suis inscrite dans toutes les agences
intérim qui correspondait à mon domaine
et le dernier je pensais que c'était
juste une formation un accompagnement
qui suis allé par curiosité et
finalement ils m'ont proposé un job ils
vont envoyer ma candidature
un de leurs partenaires et je risque
d'être contactés d'ici une semaine
malgré la neige le forum de l'emploi de
guyancourt a attiré près de 150
personnes
deux prochaines éditions pourrait suivre